thanks to strong but not too strong data
on inflation retail sales and economic
growth in recent months the US has been
enjoying what I like to call soft
Landing Summer but some analysts are
saying that the recession that most of
Wall Street predicted would hit this
year hasn't been avoided it's just been
delayed and there are three big reasons
why first some major and unexpected
government stimulus programs that have
held up the economy are going away
second those big piles of pandemic
savings have been largely exhausted for
lower income households and third the
data we've been seeing this summer could
mean the FED has more work to do let's
get into it coming into 2023 it looked
like there wouldn't be any new stimulus
coming out of Washington because
Republicans and Democrats had split
control of Congress that usually means
nothing gets done but because inflation
was so high government programs
automatically made so-called cost of
living adjustments which meant that a
lot more money was going out to
Americans receiving government transfers
the record-setting 8.7 percent increase
in Social Security benefits made
headlines but that wasn't the only
program to get a major increase in funds
SNAP benefits for food programs
retirement payments from federal and
state programs and the pay for
government contractors also went up
substantially because of these automatic
increases that has meant a lot more
money flowing through the economy in
2023 and because inflation has slowed
down so much this year those cost
increases won't be repeated in 2024. Ed
Crystal the chief U.S strategist at Ned
Davis research also points out that the
effects of the chips act and
infrastructure bills that pumped
hundreds of billions of dollars into the
economy are now being felt 2024 is an
election year and with inflation still a
major talking point Ed doesn't expect to
see a repeat of those programs next year
either many of the lower income people
who rely on government programs have
also exhausted much or all of the
pandemic savings they built up over the
past
the amount of savings folks had put away
from government stimulus checks enhanced
unemployment and just not being able to
go out and spend is much lower now Brian
Rose senior U.S Economist at UBS Global
wealth management says the U.S personal
savings rate is unsustainably low the
saving rate has dropped not just below
the record levels we saw during the
pandemic but even below its average over
the past 10 years Moody's Chief
Economist Mark Zandy tells me that new
data show Americans at lower income
tiers are having more trouble paying for
household expenses than at the beginning
of the year and more Americans across
the board are having to find irregular
income sources to meet their spending
needs the U.S economy is built on
consumers buy and that's likely to slow
down if Americans have spent down their
savings we're also seeing big increases
in Americans credit card balances and in
credit card delinquencies those two
things happening together is not great
last but not least there's the Fed
chair Jerome Powell in the Federal
Reserve have already raised U.S interest
rates to the highest in more than 20
years but with the FED determined to get
inflation back down to its two percent
Target and recent U.S GDP numbers
showing unexpected growth the FED may
have to keep raising interest rates that
would put even more pressure on U.S
companies especially small businesses
which are the economy's driving force
small business optimism has been below
its nearly 50-year average for 19
straight months making things even
tougher for small companies the fed's
latest survey shows banks have tightened
their standards for making loans to
levels that have consistently signaled a
recession for the past 50 years so
here's the big picture in 2023 inflation
has slowed down and the U.S economy is
held strong but both of those things
could be unraveling if inflation holds
at its current levels and consumer and
business spending keep falling that
recession everyone predicted in 2023
could just materialize in 2024